bonjour et merci d'être en direct avec
nous alors votre fédération appelle donc
elle grève illimitée à partir de lundi
quel est le message que vous souhaitez
faire passer
nous espérons que le conseil
constitutionnel pour a retoqué
ce projet de loi que nous estimons
liberticide on revendique le libre choix
de chaque agent chaque citoyen à pouvoir
se faire vacciner avec le vaccin qu'il
souhaite et au moment où il le souhaite
concrètement les sapeurs-pompiers qui ne
se soumettront pas cette obligation
vaccinale ne pourront plus exercer site
inévitable il leur a forcément un manque
de personnel alors d'après ce qu'on a pu
lire dans le projet de loi les mesures
seront applicables dès le lendemain de
la publication de la loi donc si la date
est maintenue au 9 août donc ça veut
dire que le 10 août déjà tous les
sapeurs pompiers qui pourront intervenir
sur le terrain devront être soit
vaccinée soit est porteur d'un tests
virologiques de moins de 48 ou 72 heures
pour le moment on ne sait pas pour
pouvoir intervenir donc ça va être très
compliqué à organiser pour les services
à 100 et de secours notamment avec les
sapeurs-pompiers volontaires qui ne sont
pas considérés comme étant des
travailleurs en france donc l'employeur
qui est quand même le se disent vas
avoir de grandes difficultés à organiser
les secours et la distribution des
secours alors l'obligation vaccinale au
sapeur pompier c'est la même que celle
qui sera peut-être imposé aux soignants
pourtant on est pas assimiler en tant
que tel c'est également ça qui vous
posent problème ce qui pose problème
effectivement c'est l'accumulation de
toutes les mesures coercitives convient
impliqués à notre profession
à chaque fois qu'on a eu à demander à
revendiquer des choses comme ça a été
fait avec les forces de l'ordre avec le
corps médical il dit un temps on nous a
dit que nous étions sapeurs-pompiers que
nous étions pas des personnels soignants
donc nous ne pouvons pas bénéficié de
telles et telles mesures qui pourraient
qui pourrait nous être favorable et
aujourd'hui lorsqu'il est question de
nous imposer une obligation vaccinale le
ministre vert en annonçant hollande
de la déclaration du président macro que
les sapeurs pompiers seront vaccinés au
prétexte qu'ils sont des transporteurs
sanitaires
nous avions toujours demandé à ne pas
être considérés comme des transporteurs
sanitaires justement où à l'époque on
demandait le recentrage et de recadrage
de nos missions sur des urgences et non
pas celui transport de malades donc
encore une fois ce que l'on considère
c'est cet engagement 7
cette obligation comme étant un mépris
un majeur de des représentants de l'état
envers notre profession est ce que vous
savez peut-être l'ampleur que va prendre
ce mouvement est ce que vous avez déjà
des retours peut-être des sapeurs
pompiers qui vont suivre cet appel à la
grève illimitée alors pour le moment ce
qu'il faut savoir c'est que ce préavis
de grève si nous ne déposons c'est que
nous répondons à une demande de nos
bases nous avons fonctionnement
démocratique nous allons demander qu'est
ce qui posait problème aujourd'hui dans
le temps nos rangs et on a eu la demande
majoritaire de déclencher un mouvement
social qui se conduit avec ce dépôt d'un
préavis coll aujourd'hui il n'y a pas
que les non vaccinés qui remettent en
cause cette obligation vaccinale
c'est une atteinte des fondamentaux de
liberté le libre choix de chacun
aujourd'hui on ne peut pas imposer à
quelqu'un d'être vaccinés avec un titre
de la kz1 s'il préférerait être vaccinés
avec un autre vaccin plus tard peut-être
celui d' institut pasteur des collègues
m'ont dit qu'ils préféreraient être
vaccinés avec des vaccins qui aurait
plus de 2 d'expérience plus de
aujourd'hui il ya un problème c'est le
problème la défiance de la société sur
ce vaccin c'est con on ne sait pas tout
on entend tout et son contraire
donc les questions légitimes qui se
posent en laurent elle se pose dans la
société et c'est tout à fait normal
vous avez bois merci d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
président national de la fédération
autonome des sapeurs pompiers
professionnels merci à vous d'avoir été
en direct sur arte france